remember the movie that put Nicolas Cage
on the map valley girl well it has been
turned into a musical it's available
tomorrow in select drive-ins and
on-demand but only I went behind the
scenes the clothing has been incredible
the clothing is so on point oversized
bows keyboard ties like way too much
neon yep dat style is in full swing in
valley girl and it should be considering
it's a remake of the classic 80s movie
it's big boots Tuco yeah I'm a big fan
of Nicolas Cage only et was on set for
the climactic prom scene Josh White
House takes over Nick's role and Jessica
Roth is your new valley girl you may
know her from happy deathday or as the
friend in green dress in lalala
[Music]
Alicia Silverstone plays the
all-grown-up valley girl
Leonardo DiCaprio's girlfriend Camilla
Barone plays her daughter you were
singing dancing on a fountain that's how
I remember it
okay so there was no fountain dancing in
the original but the remake is staying
close to its roots well we're gonna go
where would you want to go anywhere
members of the og cast told the newbies
stories from the original set the other
cast members kind of talked about all of
the torrid Affairs that happened on site
there was a lot of making out in
trailers and it looks like history
repeated itself because Logan Paul and
Chloe Bennet met on this set and dated
for a few months after our very flirty
interview it is the whatever work yeah
it's just probably you shouldn't date
people you actually like Yeah right
[Music]